but there's a man outside your window
and he's out there looking in oh and you
know it's just his job to clean the
windows that's how his day goes but the
look upon his face shows that this might
be way too close way too close you're
fully naked and he's basically a
far-away that's way too close
way too close that is what I mean when I
say you're too close I don't get what
you're saying it sounds like he was just
concerned and I feel like that is hurt
you're not getting it when there's a boy
who loves his piggy sounds like a pig
he's not a crumb palace lady says it's
time to give me piggy he's coming with
me
oh no no I got that they were farmers
never lose that he is way too close
way too close now he can barely it is
bacon and he knows it he was way too
close
way to come
wouldn't you agree he got too close is
it like when the stranger in the next
all over
for some toilet paper which is fine and
till they start to tell you all about
the day with
you asking you may talk to you while you
everything
everything
everything you don't know what the heck
is happening
[Music]
yeah haha it's way too close wait
this famil is my family away - well -
wait
this is why it's bad to be too close
this is not that boy and his piggy that
boy is probably a vegan now because he
got way too close and it's hard to be a
vegan cuz there are not as many options
I guess there's something weird
[Music]
you